This is 99% indiscipline. I'm Roman Mars. On the University of Pennsylvania campus, there's this gorgeous old library, which is the School of Design's library of Fine Arts and Architecture. It was designed by architect Frank Fernos. It looks like a red brick and terracotta palace.
这里是“纯属无纪律”。我是罗曼·马尔斯。在宾夕法尼亚大学的校园里，有一座华丽的老图书馆，它是设计学院的美术与建筑图书馆。它由建筑师弗兰克·弗内斯设计。它看起来像一座红砖和橘红色陶瓦的宫殿。
Producer Avery Trouffleman. It's got these leaded glass windows and this very elaborate roof articulated with lots of pointy ornaments and a two-story rotunda reading room. According to its website, it is a seminal library design that expresses function while merging the imagery of a cathedral and railroad station. It could be the set for any number of scenes in Harry Potter. It's a national historic landmark. It was completed in 1890.
制作人埃弗里·特鲁夫曼。它有铅条拼嵌的玻璃窗，还有非常精致的屋顶，上面点缀着许多尖尖的装饰物以及一个两层楼高的圆形大厅阅览室。根据其网站介绍，这是一座具有开创性的图书馆设计，在融合了大教堂和火车站意象的同时，表达了其功能性。它完全可以作为《哈利·波特》中好几个场景的片场。它是国家历史地标。它于1890年完工。
Now you may know the furnace library at Penn. It's a wonderful 19th century building. This is Denise Scott Brown, who studied urban planning at Penn, and then taught there. And at my first faculty meeting, they were considering whether the architecture school should support the plan to demolish the Fairness Library. This was in 1960 when architects were very into tearing down old buildings.
现在你可能知道宾大的弗内斯图书馆。这是一座绝妙的19世纪建筑。这是丹妮丝·斯科特·布朗，她在宾大学习城市规划，后来在那里教书。在我参加的第一次教员会议上，他们正在讨论建筑学院是否应该支持拆除弗内斯图书馆的计划。那是1960年，当时建筑师们非常热衷于拆除老建筑。
No one would dream of touching it now, but then I was a rebel in saying that and there was a big debate and the dean was on the other side. He wanted it to modest. It was more like modernist would do, you see. In 1960, architects thought we should be getting rid of old, frilly architecture and constructing new modern, efficient buildings of glass and steel and concrete. Denise, on the other hand, was kind of over-modernism. Not that she didn't like glass and steel and concrete. She liked the buildings themselves. She was just getting tired of the philosophies behind modernism. Not that she didn't like glass and steel and concrete. She liked the buildings themselves. She was just getting tired of the philosophies behind modernism. She was
现在没有人会做梦去碰它，但在当时，我说出这话就像个叛逆者，引发了一场激烈的辩论，而系主任持相反意见。他想把它拆掉。这更像是现代主义者的做法，你看。在1960年代，建筑师们认为我们应该摆脱陈旧、繁琐的建筑，用玻璃、钢铁和混凝土建造新的、现代的、高效的建筑。而丹妮丝则有点厌倦了现代主义。倒不是说她不喜欢玻璃、钢铁和混凝土。她其实挺喜欢这些建筑本身的。她只是厌倦了现代主义背后的哲学。倒不是说她不喜欢玻璃、钢铁和混凝土。她其实挺喜欢这些建筑本身的。她只是厌倦了现代主义背后的哲学。她
tired of architects imposing their sleek utopian visions on people without first asking people what they wanted. It was a stupid innocence to say we don't have to listen to people. They don't know what they want. We can tell them what they ought to want and we will be so good for them." And so in her first ever faculty meeting, Denise took a stand. Imagine her in her late 20s with red hair and an accent shaped by a childhood in South Africa and an education in London. She battled the dean to convince the rest of the faculty that this old library should be saved. That there's something to observing and appreciating the architecture that's already around us.
厌倦了建筑师在没有征求人们意愿的情况下，就把自己时髦的乌托邦愿景强加给大众。“那种说‘我们不必听取公众意见，他们不知道自己想要什么，我们可以告诉他们应该想要什么，这对他们最好’的想法，是一种愚蠢的天真。”因此，在她的第一场教员会议上，丹妮丝表明了立场。想象一下快30岁的她，拥有一头红发，带着南非童年和伦敦求学塑造的口音。她与系主任据理力争，说服其他教员这座老图书馆应该被保留下来。她认为去观察和欣赏我们身边已有的建筑是有价值的。
And she won them over. The whole faculty finally agreed with me, but not before a lot of argument. And after all of that, this young man came up to me and he said, I agreed with everything you said. And my name's Robert Venturi. And I said, well, why didn't you say something then? Robert Venturi, another young faculty member, didn't want to admit it at the meeting. It wasn't cool to be into extravagant old buildings then.
最终她赢得了大家的支持。全体教员最终同意了我的观点，但这之前经历了大量的争论。在那之后，这个年轻小伙子走到我面前对我说：“我同意你所说的一切，我叫罗伯特·文丘里。”我说：“那你当时怎么不说呢？”罗伯特·文丘里，另一位年轻的教员，当时在会上并不想承认这一点。在那个年代，喜欢奢华的老建筑可不是件时髦的事。
And Venturi was already kind of an outsider. He was struggling, and as the people there were saying, well, he shouldn't be there, he's not like us, he likes history, he didn't go to Harvard. Well, he went to Princeton, but he wasn't from a fancy family. And yes, he was really into historical architecture. And in Dinescott Brown, he found a kindred spirit. They began to share ideas and research. They were both very into mannerism, which is a late renaissance style of architecture that has a lot of complex decoration and exaggerated visual tricks, not unlike the furnace
而且文丘里当时已经有点像个局外人了。他当时举步维艰，正如那里的人所说，他本不该呆在那儿，他跟我们不一样，他喜欢历史，他又没去过哈佛。好吧，他是去过普林斯顿，但他并非出身豪门。而且没错，他真的很迷恋历史建筑。在丹妮丝·斯科特·布朗身上，他找到了一位志同道合的灵魂。他们开始分享彼此的想法和研究。他们俩都非常痴迷于风格主义（Mannerism），这是一种晚期文艺复兴时期的建筑风格，有着许多复杂的装饰和夸张的视觉把戏，这跟弗内斯
library. It's elaborate and fun. Denise Scott Brown and Robert Venturi worked clearly on the same page. They taught courses in conjunction with each other. From 1960 to 65, I ran one theory's course and he ran the other, and we planned them together. A colleague at Penn was so bold as to suggest, Denise, you should marry Robert Venturi. But it wasn't like that. Denise was actually a young widow at the time. She had lost her husband in a car crash pretty recently. She wasn't interested in Venturi that way.
图书馆有异曲同工之妙。它精致又有趣。丹妮丝·斯科特·布朗和罗伯特·文丘里显然非常有默契。他们共同开设课程。从1960年到1965年，我讲授一门理论课，他讲授另一门，我们是一起规划这些课程的。宾大的一位同事大胆地建议：“丹妮丝，你应该嫁给罗伯特·文丘里。”但事情并不是那样的。事实上，当时的丹妮丝是一位年轻的寡妇。她的丈夫不久前在车祸中去世了。她对文丘里并没有那种心思。
At least not yet. We were good friends. Don't forget I had lost her husband. I was a very sad person. Denise did, however, want to take her friend, Robert Venturi, to a very special place. A place she considered the anti-modernism. A place that most of her colleagues in architecture and urban planning looked at with disdain. Las Vegas.
至少当时还没有。“我们是好朋友。别忘了我刚失去丈夫，我是一个非常伤心的人。”不过，丹妮丝确实想带她的朋友罗伯特·文丘里去一个非常特别的地方。一个她认为是反现代主义的地方。一个大多数建筑和城市规划同行都用鄙视的眼光看待的地方。拉斯维加斯。
Fabulous. Las Vegas. I'm going to have to have to have a Las Vegas trip. All the scenes. See you. It's on sale. The whole scene. Vegas. And what happens in Vegas never really stays there. Together, Denise Scott Brown and Robert Venturi would find lessons in Las Vegas that would spur a new chapter in architecture. To this day, architects tend to turn their nose up at Las Vegas. Las Vegas is still a very controversial topic among architects who typically dismiss the city.
太棒了。拉斯维加斯。我得去一趟拉斯维加斯。所有的场景。再见。它在打折。整个场景。拉斯维加斯。而在拉斯维加斯发生的事，从来不会真正留在那里。丹妮丝·斯科特·布朗和罗伯特·文丘里将共同在拉斯维加斯汲取经验，开启建筑学的新篇章。直到今天，建筑师们往往对拉斯维加斯嗤之以鼻。拉斯维加斯在建筑师中仍然是一个极具争议的话题，他们通常对这座城市不屑一顾。
This is Stefan Al, a practicing architect and author of the book The Strip. Las Vegas and the architecture of the American Dream. Every time I tell my colleagues, I study Las Vegas, I get a few frowns from architecture perspective. It's a city that's known for neon, a city known for kind of decoration, a city known for kitsch, and it's exactly the the opposite of what conventionally trained architects would like. But people love Vegas. Last year there was about 45 million people
这位是斯特凡·阿尔，一名执业建筑师兼《拉斯维加斯大道：拉斯维加斯与美国梦的建筑》一书的作者。每次我告诉同事我研究拉斯维加斯时，从建筑学的角度来看，我都会收获几个皱眉。这是一座以霓虹灯闻名的城市，一座以某种装饰闻名的城市，一座以媚俗闻名的城市，这完全是传统受训建筑师所不喜欢的。但人们热爱拉斯维加斯。去年大约有4500万人
that visited Las Vegas and that was 10 million more than the city of Paris. To be clear here, we're not talking about downtown Las Vegas. We're talking about the Las Vegas strip, a long stretch of road flanked by casinos. Yeah, so a lot of people don't know that the strip is actually not built in the city of Las Vegas is actually just outside, outside of city limits. And as a result, the developers are not as much restricted by
造访了拉斯维加斯，这比巴黎这座城市还要多出1000万。需要澄清的是，我们这里讨论的不是拉斯维加斯市中心。我们讨论的是拉斯维加斯大道（The Strip），这是一条两侧林立着赌场的海滨公路。是的，所以很多人不知道，这条大道其实并不是建在拉斯维加斯市内的，它实际上就在市外，在城市边界之外。正因如此，开发商受到的
city zoning laws or city council and they have more leeway, so to say. Which is why the Vegas strip is never one static thing. It goes through radical changes almost every decade since the whole stretch of the strip is geared entirely to what will bring in the most tourists. It's designed for what's popular at a given time, so it will make as much money as possible. As soon as one of their buildings is no longer profitable or as soon as they realize they can actually build a more profitable building, then it's worth for them to implode the previous building and build something new. And this is how Vegas has always been. Constantly remaking itself, depending on what tourists want.
城市分区法律或市议会的限制较少，可以说是拥有更大的自由度。这就是为什么拉斯维加斯大道从来都不是一成不变的。自几乎每十年起，它就会经历激进的变革，因为整条大道的走向完全是为了吸引最多的游客。它是根据特定时期的流行趋势设计的，旨在赚取尽可能多的钱。一旦他们的建筑不再盈利，或者一旦他们意识到自己实际上可以建造一座更具盈利能力的建筑，那么炸毁前一座建筑并建造新建筑对他们来说就是值得的。这就是拉斯维加斯一直以来的生存之道。它根据游客的需求不断重塑自己。
It's designed and redesigned over and over again, for its visitors. The very first casino hotel complex on the strip was called El Rancho Vegas, and it had a western theme. Literally part of the advertising was bring your western boots and your western outfits and you could wear your hats. In the 1940s, western movies were popular, and the western theme made gambling seem a little more patriotic and rugged,, you know, it's what Cowboys did. So you gotta have gambling in a wild west town, a real authentic wild west town. There were never ever any Cowboys in Las Vegas,
它为游客一次又一次地被设计和重新设计。大道上第一家赌场酒店综合体名叫埃尔兰乔拉斯维加斯（El Rancho Vegas），带有西部主题。宣传内容字面意思就是：带上你的西部靴、西部服装，你还可以戴上你的帽子。在1940年代，西部电影大行其道，西部主题让赌博看起来更具爱国情怀和粗犷之美，你知道的，那是牛仔们做的事。所以你必须在一个狂野西部小镇里进行赌博，一个真正正宗的狂野西部小镇。拉斯维加斯从来没有过任何牛仔，
and so from the very beginning, Las Vegas architecture was what you could call fake. And then in the 1950s, as the fake Western Fad got tired out, they traded it in for fake mid-century suburban glamour. It really turned gambling into a suburban vacation. There were all these glamorous bungalows with kidney-shaped pools, but they all looked more or less the same. So then came the signs, starting with the Stardust Hotel in Casino.
因此从一开始，拉斯维加斯建筑就是你可以称之为“虚假”的东西。到了1950年代，随着虚假西部热潮逐渐消退，他们将其换成了虚假的世纪中期郊区魅力。它真正将赌博变成了一种郊区度假。到处都是带肾形泳池的迷人平房，但它们大同小异。于是标牌应运而生，从星尘酒店及赌场（Stardust Hotel and Casino）开始。
The Stardust was the first big horizontal sign, really big, over 200 feet long. It looked like a giant explosion. And bear in mind this was also a period in which we see the space race start to begin. The Stardust upped the anti-armic competition between the hotels on the strip. More and more massive hotels popped up with bigger and bigger signs. These were all signs that were animated, and it was a really sophisticated technology that went into these structures. It was only because the competition was so intense and it was so much a stake.
星尘是第一个大型横向标牌，体量巨大，长度超过200英尺。它看起来像一场巨大的爆炸。请记住，这也是太空竞赛刚刚开始的时期。星尘酒店加剧了大道上各酒店之间的军备竞赛。越来越多的巨型酒店拔地而起，配有越来越大的标牌。这些全都是动态标牌，这些结构凝聚了非常复杂的科技。这纯粹是因为竞争太激烈了，赌注太大了。
By the 1960s, the Las Vegas strip was a cacophony of competing neon. All these huge jarring signs almost calling out over each other. And that's what the strip looked like when Denise Scott Brown first encountered it. I had a cold chiver up my spine. And I said, is this love or is this hate? I said, I don't know. I said, photograph it anyway before it goes." She first visited Vegas in 1965, after she had left Penn to take a job at Berkeley.
到了1960年代，拉斯维加斯大道成了交织的霓虹灯发出的刺耳合奏。所有这些巨大而刺眼的标牌几乎在互相大声叫卖。当丹妮丝·斯科特·布朗第一次看到它时，大道就是这副模样。“我脊背发凉。我说，这是爱还是恨？我说，我不知道。我说，不管怎样，趁它消失前把它拍下来。”她于1965年首次访问拉斯维加斯，当时她已经离开宾大，前往伯克利任职。
Unlike the modernists who would ignore a messy place like Las Vegas, Denise found herself curious about it. Given her background in urbanism and planning, she was interested in observing the habits and patterns of people. Las Vegas was a place people voted for with their feet. They went there in droves. They really showed they liked it. They even spent money to be in it. The 1960s ship was the exact opposite of what modern architects thought the world should look like. It was loud, garish, and dazzling. It was full-blown populism. And this is what Denise loved about the strip.
与那些会忽视拉斯维加斯这样一个杂乱之地的现代主义者不同，丹妮丝发现自己对它充满了好奇。鉴于她在城市主义和规划方面的背景，她对观察人们的习惯和模式很感兴趣。拉斯维加斯是一个人们用脚投票的地方。他们蜂拥而至。他们真正表现出他们喜欢这里。他们甚至花钱来这里体验。1960年代的大道正是现代建筑师认为世界不该有的模样。它喧闹、俗气且耀眼。这是十足的平民主义。这也是丹妮丝热爱这条大道的原因。
She knew she had to show Robert Venturi. Bob was the only person I invited to Las Vegas because he was the only one interested. And then he had just adored it. In 1966, Denise Scott Brown and Robert Venturi spent four days in Las Vegas, just marveling at it. When Bob and I went to Las Vegas and had this wonderful time together,
她知道自己必须带罗伯特·文丘里来看看。“鲍勃是我邀请去拉斯维加斯的唯一一人，因为他是唯一一个感兴趣的人。然后他简直爱上它了。”1966年，丹妮丝·斯科特·布朗和罗伯特·文丘里在拉斯维加斯度过了四天，叹为观止。“当鲍勃和我去拉斯维加斯并一起度过这段美好时光时，
and suddenly he became a much more relaxed human being. We took photographs, we drove the strip, we had music on, we stopped it in in the desert and we took pictures of each other and look at the joy and the on the faces of those pictures and you see what's happening you can google pictures of Denise and Robert grinning on the strip and yeah you can really see it we fell in love after five years of working together it happened in four days in Vegas. We were in a bar, and suddenly we held hands. That's about all that happened.
突然之间，他变成了一个更加放松的人。我们拍照，我们在大道上开车，放着音乐，我们在沙漠中停下车，互相拍照，看看那些照片上脸上的喜悦，你就能看出发生了什么。”你可以在谷歌上搜到丹妮丝和罗伯特在大道上咧嘴笑的照片，是的，你真的能看出来。在一起工作五年后，我们在维加斯通过四天坠入爱河。我们在一个酒吧里，突然就手拉着手了。差不多就发生了这些。
And then we began to get more and more fond of each other. After a little back and forth, the knee-scot-brown eventually moved back to the east coast. And then one day in a taxi, I just said to him, will you marry me? And he said said yes, and yes, and yes. Robert Venturi in Denise Scott Brown got married in 1967. And together, they went to teach at Yale. But even though she was on the other side of the country, Denise wasn't done with Las Vegas, not in the least.
然后我们开始越来越喜欢彼此。经过一番推脱，丹妮丝·斯科特·布朗最终搬回了东海岸。然后有一天在出租车里，我直接对他说：“你愿意娶我吗？”他说：“愿意，愿意，非常愿意。”罗伯特·文丘里和丹妮丝·斯科特·布朗于1967年结婚。他们一起去耶鲁大学教书。但尽管身处大洋彼岸，丹妮丝对拉斯维加斯的热情还远没有结束，一点也没有。
In her teaching, Denise had taken great pains to include the elements of observation. And what better spot to observe than the strip? It was the epitome of sprawl, of loud advertisements, of shopping centers. It was American culture on steroids. The extreme case is usually a pure case. I think if you look at scientific study, it's often done that way. Let's get the most extreme version and then from that, we can know what the principles were, look for them in other places. She and Robert Venturi resolved to bring their students to the strip so they could see
在教学中，丹妮丝煞费苦心地融入了观察的元素。还有什么地方比这条大道更适合观察呢？它是城市蔓延、喧闹广告、购物中心的缩影。它是打着强心剂的美国文化。“极端情况通常就是纯粹的情况。我想如果你看一下科学研究，通常都是这样做的。让我们找到最极端的版本，然后从这个版本中，我们可以了解其原则是什么，并在其他地方寻找它们。”她和罗伯特·文丘里决定带他们的学生去这条大道，让他们亲眼看看。
it themselves. Venturi and Scott Brown planned a 12-week-long studio studying Las Vegas for 13 students. 10 days of this course would actually be spent on the strip itself. We were all put up at the star dust. Scott Brown and Venturi got comped rooms for them and all the students who took full advantage of the freedom they had off campus. We didn't notice when we went into their rooms, the smell of marijuana, because I just didn't know that smell. Out in the field, under Denise and Robert's eye, the students did a lot of watching and took many, many photographs. Some of which were taken from reclusive millionaire Howard Hughes' helicopter. He made available on our use of one of his helicopters.
文丘里和斯科特·布朗为13名学生规划了一个为期12周的拉斯维加斯工作室。这门课程中有10天实际上是在大道本身度过的。“我们都住在星尘酒店。”斯科特·布朗和文丘里为他们和所有学生争取到了免费房间，他们充分利用了校外的自由。“当我们走进他们的房间时，我们没有注意到大麻的气味，因为我根本不知道那种气味。”在实地，在丹妮丝和罗伯特的注视下，学生们进行了大量的观察，拍摄了许许多多的照片。其中一些照片是从隐居亿万富翁霍华德·休斯（Howard Hughes）的直升机上拍摄的。“他让我们免费使用他的其中一架直升机。
That was very useful and we got very good pictures. And with Denise's help, the students finagled their way into the grand opening gala of the circus, circus casino. And they had got themselves dressed up. They went to the thrift shop in Las Vegas. In the midst of all the fun, the students were still really engaged with the labor of truly looking at a place. The students observed traffic patterns,
这非常有用，我们拍到了非常好的照片。”在丹妮丝的帮助下，学生们巧妙地混入了马戏马戏赌场（Circus Circus casino）的大型开业庆典。他们盛装打扮。他们去了拉斯维加斯的旧货店。在所有的欢乐之中，学生们依然全心投入到真正审视一个地方的工作中。学生们观察交通模式，
conducted interviews, and made maps and diagrams. Basically, all the things architecture students would normally do to observe Athens or Rome. But like this time they were sitting and drawing sketches of parking lots. We had a set of topics. Many of them were patterns of distribution, like where are churches in Las Vegas compared with New Haven, where are redding chapels, people with a distribution map. Denise compared the strip to a bizarre or a
进行采访，并制作地图和图表。基本上就是建筑系学生通常用来观察雅典或罗马的所有事情。但这一次，他们坐着画停车场草图。“我们有一组主题。其中许多是分布模式，比如与纽黑文相比，拉斯维加斯的教堂在哪里，红娘小教堂在哪里，人们拿着一张分布图。”丹妮丝将这条大道比作一个集市或
marketplace but built on a scale for cars. The market is a foot market and you see the actual goods in the window of the store and you smell them when you arrive in the market. But on the strip instead of the sights and smells of the items for sale or the merchants hollering and peddling goods there are signs that call out and beckon to you. What's the anatomy of a big Las Vegas sign? It has its high reader, its low reader. How does that really, in relation to the small sign,
市场，但它是按汽车的尺度建造的。市场是一个步行的市场，你可以在商店橱窗里看到真正的商品，当你到达市场时能闻到它们的香味。但在大道上，没有了待售商品的景象和气味，也没有商贩的叫卖和推销，取而代之的是向你大声呼喊并向你招手的标牌。拉斯维加斯巨型标牌的解剖结构是什么？它有高位读者、低位读者。它如何真正地与小标牌相关联，
well, all of them put on the site? How do they draw you in, where do you see them from? And in observing the strip, and the way cars and people navigate it, they found that Las Vegas worked. The signs served their purpose. The strip was navigable. It functioned in the midst of its apparent chaos.
好吧，所有这些都放置在现场？它们是如何吸引你进去的，你在哪里可以看到它们？在观察大道以及汽车和人们在其中导航的方式时，他们发现拉斯维加斯是行之有效的。标牌起到了它们的作用。大道是畅通无阻的。它在表面上的混乱中发挥着功能。
Like there would be an Arabian-themed sign for an Arabian-themed casino, and venues advertised the evening's performers in big lights. Everything was spelled out very clearly in a way that was appealing to people. And so Robert Venturi and Denise Scott Brown took all the maps and notes and observations that they and the students had collected. And together, with their teaching assistant and co-author Stephen Eisenhower, they put it all in a book.
比如，会有一个阿拉伯风格的赌场配有阿拉伯风格的标牌，场馆用巨型灯光宣传晚上的表演。一切都以对人们有吸引力的方式非常清晰地拼写出来。于是，罗伯特·文丘里和丹妮丝·斯科特·布朗收集了他们和学生们收集的所有地图、笔记和观察结果。他们与助教兼合著者史蒂芬·艾森豪尔（Stephen Izenour）一起，将这一切写成了一本书。
A book published in 1972 called Learning from Las Vegas. What happens next? Everyone reads that book. This is architecture and design critic Alexander Lang, and she says learning from Las Vegas challenged architects to take the architecture of Vegas, what they call the architecture of the American highway, seriously. And that it too has a structure, and it too has lessons that we can learn from. And so let's stop being snobby and only kind of talking about architecture within architecture,
一本出版于1972年的书，名为《向拉斯维加斯学习》。接下来会发生什么？每个人都读过那本书。这位是建筑与设计评论家亚历山大·朗（Alexandra Lange），她说《向拉斯维加斯学习》挑战了建筑师，让他们认真对待拉斯维加斯的建筑——他们称之为美国高速公路的建筑。它也有自己的结构，它也有我们可以学习的经验。所以让我们停止势利，不要只在建筑内部空谈建筑，
and look at what's actually out there in the world and what we can learn from it. It's not just saying, hey Vegas is cool, it's saying here's a whole approach to the world that we actually live in. And truly, everyone studying architecture read this book. Why did it catch on? Because people were searching for a way out of the dead end, the dead end of modernism, and this book written by kind of the coolest kids in architecture seemed like it might be that way out. By 1980, learning from Las Vegas becomes
而是去看看世界上实际存在的东西以及我们可以从中学到什么。这不仅仅是说“嘿，维加斯很酷”，而是说“这里有一种针对我们实际生活的世界的方法”。真的，所有学习建筑的人都读过这本书。为什么它会流行起来？因为人们在寻找一条摆脱死胡同的出路，即现代主义死胡同的出路，而这本由建筑界最酷的孩子们写就的书似乎就是那条出路。到1980年，《向拉斯维加斯学习》成了
a text assigned in every architecture school. And that is a huge deal because it means American architects can't ignore the built environment that's all around them. Although Venturi got most of the credit. Look, I never get the famous all. It's Robert Venturi and what's that wife doing hanging in there? But learning from Las Vegas derives from Denise's experience on the strip, which she then invited Venturi along for. Not to mention Denise's background in observation and planning and her belief that spaces should be designed with people in mind.
每个建筑学校指定的必读文本。这是一件大事，因为这意味着美国建筑师无法忽视他们身边的建筑环境。尽管文丘里获得了大部分功劳。“看，我从来没能出名。总是罗伯特·文丘里，那个妻子在里面瞎掺和什么？”但《向拉斯维加斯学习》源于丹妮丝在大道的经历，然后她邀请了文丘里同行。更不用说丹妮丝在观察和规划方面的背景，以及她认为空间设计应该以人为本的信念。
The idea that architecture needed to say something to the maximum number of people, not just to people who were educated in the themes of architecture. Venturians got brown loved the historical elements of architecture that anyone could recognize. And so they say, you know what? People love houses with gables.
建筑需要向最多的人传达某些信息的理念，而不仅仅是向那些受过建筑主题教育的人传达。文丘里和斯科特·布朗热爱任何人都能认出来的建筑历史元素。所以他们说：“你知道吗？人们喜欢带山墙的房子。
People like their banks to have columns up front. So let's do that. Columns can signify that a building is important since they're associated with banks and government buildings. A triangular roof means that the building is a house. And if those elements help people to understand the building, architects should just go ahead and add them. Denise Unrobert puts some of these ideas into practice in their own work. One of the more extreme examples is their design for the Children's Museum of Houston. They put these oversized Greek columns in the front, which signal that it's a museum, but
人们喜欢他们的银行前面有柱子。那我们就这样做吧。柱子可以表明一座建筑很重要，因为它们与银行和政府建筑联系在一起。三角形的屋顶意味着这座建筑是一座房子。如果这些元素有助于人们理解建筑，建筑师就应该直接把它们加进去。”丹妮丝和罗伯特将其中一些想法付诸实践。其中一个比较极端的例子是他们为休斯顿儿童博物馆（Children's Museum of Houston）做的设计。他们在正面放置了这些超大的希腊柱，这表明这是一个博物馆，但
because it's a children's museum, the columns are bright, canary, yellow. And the columns hold up a massive sign that says, Museum, in big red letters. You don't have to wonder if you've made it to the right spot. It's pretty clear. And they did this for adult museums too. For example, in Seattle Art Museum there's a sign on the top of the building. It just says, S-A-M, Seattle Art Museum. It is very big.
因为这是一个儿童博物馆，这些柱子是明亮的金丝雀黄色。这些柱子支撑着一个巨大的标牌，上面用巨大的红字写着“博物馆”。你不用怀疑自己是否走对了地方。这非常清晰。他们对成人博物馆也这样做。例如，在西雅图艺术博物馆（Seattle Art Museum），建筑顶部有一个标牌。上面只写着：S-A-M，西雅图艺术博物馆。它非常巨大。
I mean, not all their buildings had giant overt signs on them, but the point is Robert Venturian to Nyscot Brown were not afraid of signs. They were not afraid of color, and they were not afraid of historical motifs. Their work in their architecture and writing was about making sure buildings were accessible and understandable to as many people as possible. In this morphed into one of the most controversial movements in architecture. Postmodernism. Postmodernism was a way for buildings to be communicative, deeply meaningful, and fun. Although the problem is a lot of designers just focused on the fun part. So some postmodern
我的意思是，并非他们的所有建筑上都有巨大的显眼标牌，但重点是罗伯特·文丘里和丹妮丝·斯科特·布朗并不害怕标牌。他们不怕色彩，也不怕历史母题。他们在建筑和写作中的工作，是为了确保建筑对尽可能多的人来说是可及的和可理解的。这演变成了建筑史上最具争议的运动之一。后现代主义。后现代主义是建筑具有传达性、深刻意义和趣味性的一种方式。虽然问题在于许多设计师只关注有趣的部分。所以一些后现代
architecture takes the kind of the jazzyness of Vegas, takes the colors, takes the neon, and that becomes one form of postmodernism. A lot of architects and designers were just like, oh cool, now we can use neon and bright colors and big signs and slap on historical styles and details without any meaning. Just for the fun of it. In other words, it became part of the aesthetics of the 80s. Bright colors, bold shapes. This is what a lot of people mean by an aesthetic of postmodernism.
建筑汲取了维加斯的爵士风，汲取了色彩、霓虹灯，这就成了后现代主义的一种形式。许多建筑师和设计师觉得：“噢太酷了，现在我们可以使用霓虹灯、鲜艳的色彩和大标牌，然后生搬硬套上历史风格和细节，而不需要任何意义。纯粹为了好玩。”换句话说，它成了80年代美学的一部分。明亮的色彩，大胆的形状。这就是许多人所说的后现代主义美学。
Just kind of goofy without substance. It goes in all of these different directions, and I think Tini's got brown really hates some of those directions because they don't have the interpretive quality that they brought to their version of postmodernism. And as postmodernism became sillier and sillier, it strayed further and further away from what Denise Scott Brown and Robert Venturi were originally trying to do. It became hard for clients to see how deeply intentional and thoughtful their work was. You know, it wasn't like when Triumph to another after they wrote that book by any means. We'd probably had more work if we hadn't done all this.
有点傻气却没有内涵。它朝着所有这些不同的方向发展，我认为丹妮丝·斯科特·布朗真的很讨厌其中的某些方向，因为它们缺乏他们带入自己版本的后现代主义中的那种诠释品质。随着后现代主义变得越来越荒诞，它离丹妮丝·斯科特·布朗和罗伯特·文丘里最初的尝试越来越远。客户很难看出他们的作品是多么具有深度意图和深思熟虑。“你知道的，他们写完那本书之后，也并没有订单不断。如果我们不搞这些，我们可能还会有更多的工作。”
Their books, their buildings, championing places like the Las Vegas strip. They were definitely times when they didn't have them any clients and it was very difficult for them to get work. Ultimately, postmodernism's popularity was short-lived. So what happened with postmodernism's popularity was short-lived. So what happened with postmodernism is it really did not last very long
他们的书籍、他们的建筑，都在捍卫像拉斯维加斯大道这样的地方。绝对有他们接不到任何客户、很难找到工作的时候。归根结底，后现代主义的流行是短暂的。那么后现代主义的流行究竟是怎么回事呢？后现代主义之所以短暂，是因为它作为一场建筑运动
as an architectural movement. It has basically a 10-year, approximately 10-year heyday, you can say, kind of early 80s to early 90s. And then it just goes really out of fashion. The clients sort of revert back to wanting things that look modernist and architecture reverts back to its previous form. People go back to wanting faceless buildings in shades of gray and black, made of glass
确实没有持续很久。你可以说它基本上只有10年左右的鼎盛时期，大约从80年代初到90年代初。然后它就彻底过时了。客户们某种程度上又回到了想要现代主义风格的东西，建筑也回到了以前的形式。人们又开始想要灰色和黑色色调、由玻璃和钢材制成的无面孔建筑。
and steel. And if people want it, Las Vegas will deliver it. Yeah, so that's the big irony of it all. Architect and strip historian Stefan Alligan. As they publish the book, learning from Las Vegas and Las Vegas becomes known as the birthplace of postmodernism and celebrating signage and moving away from boring modernism. This is actually when Las Vegas turns to the opposite as ever Vegas was ahead of the curve. The strip had already started to revert to corporate modernism, even before learning from
如果人们想要，拉斯维加斯就会提供。是的，这就是这一切最大的讽刺之处。建筑师兼大道历史学家斯特凡·阿尔说道。当他们出版《向拉斯维加斯学习》一书，拉斯维加斯被称为后现代主义的发源地、庆祝标牌并远离无聊的现代主义时，实际上正是拉斯维加斯转向反面的时候，维加斯总是走在时代前沿。甚至在《向拉斯维加斯学习》出版之前，大道就已经开始回归企业现代主义。
Las Vegas was published. In 1967, the state of Nevada passes the Corporate Gaming Act, which allows big corporations and hotel chains to own and operate casinos. So, Frances De Hilton became a casino operator on the Las Vegas strip, and they built following their own aesthetic, which was a corporate modernism, and it was precisely this style of architecture that Denise Cobran and Robert Venturi lamented. That's a big irony. But of course, this isn't the end of the story. The strip, after all, is always reinventing itself, responding to what consumers want.
1967年，内华达州通过了《企业博彩法案》（Corporate Gaming Act），允许大公司和连锁酒店拥有和经营赌场。因此，希尔顿等公司成为拉斯维加斯大道的赌场运营商，他们按照自己的美学进行建设，这是一种企业现代主义，而正是这种建筑风格让丹妮丝·斯科特·布朗和罗伯特·文丘里感到惋惜。这是一个巨大的讽刺。当然，这还不是故事的全部。毕竟，大道总是在不断重塑自己，以回应消费者的需求。
The big glassy towers continue to rise until, in 1989, Steve Winn stuck a giant erupting volcano in front of the Mirage Hotel. This brings in the Disneyland era, when Casinos started to build crazy, expensive attractions. Treasure Island, which had a big sinking pirate ship, the big Cinderella castle Excalibur, and then came the next phase of the ship. Let's call it vacation land. Fake Venice with fake canals and gondoliers who sing to you, fake Paris with a fake Eiffel Tower.
巨大的玻璃塔楼不断拔地而起，直到1989年，史蒂夫·韦恩（Steve Wynn）在幻影酒店（Mirage Hotel）门前竖起了一座巨大的爆发火山。这带来了迪士尼乐园时代，当时赌场开始建造疯狂而昂贵的景点。金银岛酒店（Treasure Island）有一艘正在下沉的海盗船，灰姑娘式的城堡神剑酒店（Excalibur），接着是大道的下一阶段。我们称之为度假乐园。带有假运河和为你唱歌的刚朵拉船夫的假威尼斯，带有假埃菲尔铁塔的假巴黎。
And then, in the new millennium, Vegas welcomed a batch of new casinos, designed by big-name prestigious architects. They're trying to appeal to millennials by making Vegas look like a cutting-edge city. These drinks are like $16. And soon, without a doubt, the strip will shape shift again. This is all just to say, the Vegas strip is in such a constant state of flux and renewal. It only barely resembles the city that was chronicled in learning from Las Vegas. But it almost doesn't matter that Vegas has changed, or that postmodernism as an architectural
然后，在新千年来临之际，维加斯迎来了由大牌声誉卓著的建筑师设计的一批新赌场。他们试图通过让维加斯看起来像一座前沿城市来吸引千禧一代。这些饮料售价16美元。不久之后，毫无疑问，大道将再次发生形态转变。这一切只是为了说明，拉斯维加斯大道处于不断的变迁和更新之中。它几乎已经不像《向拉斯维加斯学习》中所记录的那座城市了。但维加斯变了，或者后现代主义作为一个建筑
movement was a short one. As Denise Scott Brown herself has often said, learning from Las Vegas is not about Las Vegas. Here's critic Alexander Lang again. The point is to use the tools, you know, really the critical tools, like they are writing as critics of the American landscape to apply to your own landscape, your own situation. Learning from Las Vegas has helped architects open their minds, reserve judgment, and learn from the everyday built environment around them.
运动是短暂的，这几乎都无关紧要。正如丹妮丝·斯科特·布朗自己经常说的那样，《向拉斯维加斯学习》讲的不是拉斯维加斯。这里再次请出评论家亚历山大·朗。重点是使用这些工具，你知道的，真正的批判工具，就像他们以美国景观批评家的身份写作那样，将其应用到你自己的景观、你自己的处境中。《向拉斯维加斯学习》帮助建筑师敞开心扉，保留判断，并向他们周围日常的建筑环境学习。
If you do want to observe the changing ever-shifting state of the American landscape, there's still no better place to see it than the Las Vegas strip. Every time I go to Las Vegas, I see something new. And if you want to stay ahead of the curve as an architect, it's good every now and then to visit Las Vegas. Denise Scott Brown went back to Vegas a few more times and witnessed many of these changes,
如果你确实想观察美国景观不断变化、瞬息万变的状态，仍然没有比拉斯维加斯大道更好的地方了。每次我去拉斯维加斯，我都会看到新的东西。如果你想作为一名建筑师保持领先地位，时不时去拉斯维加斯看看是很有好处的。丹妮丝·斯科特·布朗又回过几次维加斯，见证了许多这些变化，
but it's been a while now. I haven't been there recently. And what I learned from the Disneyland, the theme park era was that they were very talented in doing that. But you know, we have always turned on designing a casino. That was not the point for us. But also no one asked us. Easy to turn it down. We do not ask. That's called Sour Grapes. Denise Scott Brown and Robert Venturi are still together. And now they live back in Philadelphia,
但现在已经有一段时间没去了。我最近没有去过那里。我从迪士尼乐园、主题公园时代学到的是，他们在做这件事时非常有才华。但你知道，我们一直致力于设计赌场。这对我们来说不是重点。而且也没有人问过我们。拒绝起来很容易。我们不问。这就叫吃不到葡萄说葡萄酸。丹妮丝·斯科特·布朗和罗伯特·文丘里依然在一起。现在他们搬回了费城居住，
just a 30 minute drive away from the Red Brick Library designed by Frank Fernos. A wonderful 19th century, mannerist building. Bob and I regenerated this, amazed it into the architecture library. No one would dream of touching it now. In 1986, Robert Venturi and Denise Scott Brown worked on the master plan for the restoration
距离弗兰克·弗内斯设计的红砖图书馆只有30分钟的车程。一座美妙的19世纪风格主义建筑。“鲍勃和我对它进行了翻新，将其改造成了建筑图书馆。现在没有人会做梦去碰它了。”1986年，罗伯特·文丘里和丹妮丝·斯科特·布朗参与了弗内斯图书馆修复的总规划，这座建筑正是将他们的生活和思想交织在一起的建筑。
of the furnace library, the very building that brought their lives and their ideas together. It's everyone's favorite architecture game, Duck or Decorated Shed. Right after this. We're back in the studio with Avery Trophman with a little addendum to the learning from Las Vegas story. There's this one really famous takeaway from learning from Las Vegas that we didn't cover in the story because it kind of eclipses the rest of the book. Architects tend to say, you had only one finding, the doc and the decorated shit.
这是每个人最喜欢的建筑游戏：鸭子还是装饰棚。广告之后见。我们回到了由埃弗里·特罗夫曼主持的演播室，为大家带来关于《向拉斯维加斯学习》故事的一点小附录。关于《向拉斯维加斯学习》有一个非常著名的结论，我们在故事里没有涵盖，因为它有点盖过了这本书的其他内容。建筑师往往会说，你们只有一个发现，那就是鸭子和装饰棚。
We had 10, 15 or 20 findings and they haven't rid the stuff well enough and learned how to use it. I'm one of those people that loves the concept of the duck versus the decorated shed just because it has a great name. It has a great name. So, I mean, we can cut this out if we need to, but should I give a shot of what I think it is and maybe correct me? Sure, yeah. So what's the duck in the decorated shed, Robert? Okay, so there are two types of buildings.
我们有10个、15个或20个发现，而他们没有把东西读透，也没有学会如何使用它。我是那种热爱鸭子对阵装饰棚这个概念的人，仅仅因为它的名字很好听。它的名字很好听。所以，我的意思是，如果需要的话我们可以把它剪掉，但我应该试着说一下我认为它是什么，也许你可以纠正我？当然，可以。那么，罗伯特，什么是鸭子，什么是装饰棚？好吧，有两种类型的建筑。
There's a duck, which is a building with the form that represents the thing that's inside of it. And then there's the decorated shed, which is essentially a box with a sign on it. More or less. More or less, but it gets, it gets, so that is what it is in theory, but then as you apply it to the real world, if you look around looking for ducks and decorated sheds, it gets kind of complicated.
一种是鸭子，这是一种建筑，其形式代表了它内部包含的东西。另一种是装饰棚，本质上就是一个带有标牌的盒子。差不多吧。差不多，但它变得，它变得，这在理论上是这样的，但当你把它应用到现实世界中，如果你环顾四周寻找鸭子和装饰棚，情况就会变得有点复杂。
Yeah, every time I teach the duck and the decorated shed, I have to go and reread it. And I probably should have gone and reread it. It's strangely difficult. So, design critic, Alexandra Lang is going to help us out. A decorated shed is a building that is a box that could contain anything. And it has a sign out front that indicates what happens inside. So yeah, pretty much a decorated shed. You got it.
是的，每次我教鸭子和装饰棚的时候，我都得去重新阅读它。我本该去重新阅读的。它出奇地难。所以，设计评论家亚历山大·朗将为我们解惑。装饰棚是一座可以容纳任何东西的盒状建筑。它的前面有一个标牌，表明里面发生了什么。所以，是的，差不多就是装饰棚。你懂的。
A decorated shed is pretty much what it sounds like. It's a simple, it's not necessarily a box, but it is a simple and generic building with a sign or a decoration on it, like the Stardust Hotel, which Denise was staying in. That was a facade, a mile long, just blazing with neon. And we walked round the back, and Bob said, the back of this building is far less decorated than what a group has ever dreamed of, and we call that the shed.
装饰棚正如其听起来的那样。它是一个简单的、不一定是盒子但简单且通用的建筑，上面有标牌或装饰，就像丹妮丝曾经入住的星尘酒店那样。那是一个长达一英里的立面，霓虹灯闪烁。我们走到后面，鲍勃说：“这座建筑的背面比任何人想象的都要少得多装饰，我们称之为棚子。”
So decorated sheds are actually quite common, if you think of like a big box store, if it goes out of business and another business moves in, they just change the sign and it completely functions. And I think the interesting thing about learning from Las Vegas and Scott Brown and Venturi's work is that what they're basically saying is like, decorated sheds are not a bad thing. That is one of the main points learning from Las Vegas is trying to prove that signs are a really efficient way for
所以装饰棚其实很常见，如果你想想一个大卖场，如果它倒闭了，另一家企业搬进去，他们只需要换个招牌就能完全运转。我认为《向拉斯维加斯学习》以及斯科特·布朗和文丘里的作品有趣的地方在于，他们基本上是在说：装饰棚并不是一件坏事。这是《向拉斯维加斯学习》试图证明的主要观点之一，即标牌是
a building to communicate. So we were getting this model of the shed all over the place, but I was walking down in front of the art and architecture building in New Haven, and I looked up and I said, you know, it's got no decoration, but the whole thing is a piece of decoration, which brings us to the duck. The duck. So that's the idea of the whole building being a decoration. Do you know why it's called the duck?
建筑进行沟通的高效方式。所以我们到处都能看到这种棚子的模型，但当我在纽黑文的艺术与建筑大楼前走过时，我抬起头说：“你知道，它没有装饰，但整个建筑本身就是一件装饰品。”这就把我们引向了鸭子。鸭子。这就是整栋建筑本身就是一件装饰的想法。你知道为什么它被称为鸭子吗？
I don't. So it's actually, there's this famous building on the side of the road in Long Island, literally shaped like a duck. And it sold duck. And it sold duck eggs. It's niche. Well, of course, it, and it sold duck eggs. It's niche. Well, of course, it sells a lot of duck, and it doesn't really matter what the shape is
我不知道。实际上，在长岛路边有一座著名的建筑，字面意思就是鸭子的形状。它卖鸭子。它卖鸭蛋。这是细分市场。当然，它，它卖很多鸭子，至于里面的形状是什么其实并不重要，
inside. There's room for all the activity that goes on there, even if it's shaped like a duck. There aren't a lot of buildings shaped like the very thing they're selling. That's pretty rare. There's one outside of where I grew up, which is one of the reasons why I know this, and it resonated with me. What is it? So, I lived for a stretch of my childhood in Newark, Ohio.
里面有空间容纳所有在那里进行的活动，即使它的形状像一只鸭子。形状像它们所销售的东西的建筑并不多。这相当罕见。在我长大的地方外面就有一座，这也是我知道这一点的原因之一，它引起了我的共鸣。是什么？我在俄亥俄州纽瓦克度过了一段童年时光。
And outside Newark, Ohio is the, starts with an L-basket company. I don't know what it's called. Oh, I know that building. They sold baskets and they had a building shaped like a big picnic basket. It's like one of the rare like pure forms of duck. That's so cool. But then the interesting thing is like, Frank Gary buildings can technically be ducks.
在俄亥俄州纽瓦克外面是那个，以L开头的篮子公司。我不知道它叫什么。哦，我知道那座建筑。他们卖篮子，他们有一座形状像大野餐篮的建筑。这就像是鸭子的罕见纯粹形式之一。太酷了。但有趣的是，弗兰克·盖里的建筑在技术上可以说是鸭子。
Frank Gary is like Mr. Duck. Because those are statement buildings that are not decorated per se, like they don't have ornaments on them, but they are built out as an entire piece of decoration in and of themselves, like with Gary, he has these crazy, curved metal exteriors that force the interiors to accommodate it.
弗兰克·盖里就像是鸭子先生。因为这些是有宣言性质的建筑，它们本身并没有经过什么装饰，比如它们上面没有装饰物，但它们作为一个整体的装饰品被建造出来，就像盖里一样，他有这些疯狂的、弯曲的金属外观，迫使内部空间去适应它。
So it's kind of counterintuitive because you would be inclined to think, well, modern buildings are sheds because they're very minimalist. But yeah, there's this whole argument to be made that a lot of modernist architecture was very preoccupied with making ducks. What they call the heroic and original architects,
所以这有点违反直觉，因为你倾向于认为现代建筑是棚子，因为它们非常极简主义。但是，是的，有一个充分的论据可以说明，许多现代主义建筑非常全神贯注于制造鸭子。他们所称的英雄主义和原创建筑师，
people like Paul Rudolph and the brutalists, made a building that looked like, you know, did all kinds of crazy things to try to express what it did inside, but actually often made, you know, rooms that were unusable or balconies that nobody would ever hang out on. But that's not to say that ducks are bad.
像保罗·鲁道夫和粗野主义者，建造了一座看起来像……你知道的，做了各种疯狂的事情来试图表达它内部的功能，但实际上往往建造出你知道的无法使用的房间，或者根本没有人会闲逛的阳台。但这并不是说鸭子不好。
And some buildings should be ducks, you know? Or some buildings should have duck-like parts of them because the inside is less important than the outside. The little airport buildings that need something on them to make them show from the air, it would help them do their jobs better, but they better have a big red checkerboard pattern. So no play will fly into them. For a while, when we went to give a lecture,
有些建筑应该成为鸭子，你知道吗？或者有些建筑应该有类似鸭子的部分，因为内部比外部不那么重要。那些需要某种东西让它们在空中显现出来的小型机场建筑，这会有助于它们更好地完成工作，但它们最好有一个巨大的红色棋盘图案。这样就不会有飞机撞上它们了。有一段时间，当我们去作演讲时，
it usually would be someone dressed like a duck on the stage with us. So which was a nice sign of kind of something happening. So I guess you were pretty much right. But what do you think, anything surprising in there? Well, it widened my scope of what a duck is. I can see why even if you're really smart like Alexander Lang, who's way smarter about architecture than me or anyone in the building, that you would kind of have to look it up.
通常舞台上会有一个打扮成鸭子的人和我们在一起，这也是某种事情发生的不错信号。所以我想你基本上是对的。但你觉得呢，里面有什么令人惊讶的吗？嗯，它拓宽了我对“鸭子”的理解。我能明白为什么即使你像亚历山大·朗那样聪明——他对建筑的了解远胜于我或大楼里的任何人——你有时也得去查一下。
Like is maybe the Apple campus a duck? I mean, I think there's a case to be made that it's a duck. Are there any other sort of edge cases that we could talk about? I'm trying to think, well, I'm also thinking of like other hotels on the Las Vegas strip, you know? Right. Like, some of them really walk that line. I'm thinking particularly of like New York New York Hotel,
比如苹果园区算是一只“鸭子”吗？我的意思是，我认为有理由证明它是一只“鸭子”。还有没有其他我们可以讨论的边缘案例？我在想，嗯，我也在想拉斯维加斯大道的其他酒店，你知道的？对的。比如，其中有些酒店真的很游走于这条界限边缘。我特别想到的是像纽约纽约酒店，
which has this, it looks like the skyline of Manhattan. And I can't tell if that is like a front on a bunch of buildings. You know, it's hard to tell what is the sign and what is the shape of the building, especially when you get to the Vegas strip. It's funny that Vegas ends up being the best form of examples of both. Yeah. Wow.
它有这个，看起来像曼哈顿的天际线。我分不清这到底是一群建筑的正面装饰，还是怎么回事。你知道的，很难分辨什么是招牌，什么是建筑的形状，特别是当你来到拉斯维加斯大道时。有趣的是，拉斯维加斯最终成了这两者最好的范例。是的。哇。
Learning from Las Vegas. There we go. Cool. Thanks. I looked it up afterwards, and it is the Longer Burger Basket Building that's in New Org Ohio, and it does, and it looks like a giant picnic basket. It is no longer owned by the Lungenberger company, but the current plans are to preserve it
《向拉斯维加斯学习》。就是这样。酷。谢谢。我事后查了一下，那是位于俄亥俄州纽瓦克的朗根贝格篮子大楼，它确实长得像一个巨大的野餐篮。它已经不再由朗根贝格公司所有，但目前的计划是将其完整地保留下来，
in all of its magnificent darkness. 99% of Israel was produced this week by Avery Trouffleman, Mix and Tech Production by Sharif Yusuf, Music by Sean Rial. Delaney Hall is the senior editor, Kurt Colstead is the digital director. Katie Mingle is our senior producer. The rest of the team includes Emmett Fitzgerald,
保留其全部壮丽的黑暗面。本周的 99% Invisible 由 Avery Trouffleman 制作，混音和技术制作由 Sharif Yusuf 负责，音乐由 Sean Rial 提供。Delaney Hall 是资深编辑，Kurt Colstead 是数字总监。Katie Mingle 是我们的资深制作人。团队其他成员包括 Emmett Fitzgerald、
Taren Mazza, and me, Roman Mars. Special thanks this week to Adam Nathaniel Furman with fact checking by Graham Haysha. We are a project of 91.7 KALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful downtown, Oakland, California. We are part of Radio Topia from PRX, a collective of the best most innovative shows in all of podcasting. We are supported by our listeners, just like you. You can find 99% of visible and
Taren Mazza，以及我，Roman Mars。本周特别感谢 Adam Nathaniel Furman，事实核查由 Graham Haysha 负责。我们是旧金山 91.7 KALW 的一个项目，在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心 Radio Row 制作。我们是来自 PRX 的 Radiotopia 的一部分，这是一个汇集了所有播客中最优秀、最具创新性节目的集合。我们得到像你这样的听众的支持。你可以找到 99% Invisible 并
join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PI org. We're on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. But we have an explainer of the duck versus the decorated shed that Kurt wrote up on our website. It's 99pi.org. Radio to P.I. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在 Facebook 上加入关于节目的讨论。你可以在 Twitter 上@我 @Roman Mars 以及节目 @99PI org。我们也在 Instagram、Tumblr 和 Reddit 上。不过我们在网站上有一篇关于“鸭子”与“装饰棚”的解释文章，是 Kurt 写的。网址是 99pi.org。来自 PRX 的 Radiotopia。本集暂时还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。